you know Hollywood must feel like a
ghost town right now because so many
stars are here in the ATL as we
countdown to Super Bowl 53 I had a
chance to hang out today with Kevin Hart
Jenny McCarthy the Backstreet Boys Luke
Wilson so many folks are here but first
let's start with a few big surprises who
could join Adam Levine and maroon 5
onstage during the halftime show will we
have a few new clues for you I've been
at the helm of this thing and putting it
together and with the guests as well
it's been a it's been a process this is
the the show that's gonna have the
biggest hip-hop presence that there has
ever been so who are these top secret
guests that Adam has called in
the biggest clue dropped during our
exclusive sit-down they could appear
during the band's female empowerment
anthem girls like you it's great to be
planned potentially playing the song
it's super bowl-like
you how will you incorporate that
because you had a lot of famous faces in
that video that's a lot of people trust
me just wrangling that many people for
the video in general was tough enough so
I can't promise that every single person
to be there for the Super Bowl it has
been speculated cardi B could make a
cameo in bed there's the Kristina factor
[Music]
she played coy with et a few days ago
you have some history a weeds in know
what do you think Murray fives could
bring to the stage I mean I don't they
have the lineup right and check out what
she said last night on watch what
happens live any talks of you joining
maroon 5 for the Super Bowl
lead the face okay of course Christina
is no stranger to the Super Bowl
halftime show
in 2008 II was there when the then
nineteen year old took the stage with
enrique inglesias pretty amazing right
yeah you just get really into it what's
right on stage and like the lights it's
just incredible really an adrenaline
rush she returned in 2011 to sing the
national anthems
can you see and I was with Atlanta's
legendary Gladys Knight who will take
that honor this year what will it mean
when you step on that field to sing the
national anthem
everything I'm serious the fact that I'm
at home mm-hmm Atlanta Georgia is my
home
[Music]